Now, comes the answer--option D would mean that we have a huge amount of immigration
of recovered persons--no.
Option B would mean that the number of susceptible persons is reduced
by 100 persons per day that looks like immigration but not like vaccination.
With option A, we would be changing this coefficient.
If you remember where this coefficient came from, it had to do with the probability of being infected,
mainly more precised with the probability that a susceptible person is infected
by an infectious person and it had to do with the number of contacts.
It doesn't have to do with vaccination.
It's option C, we move 5 million persons from the susceptible compartment
to the recovered compartment.
Of course, we're cheating a little there. These 5 million persons have not recovered from the illness.
They are immune as are all other recovered persons.